so I I have to say this you this is I
mean you're from cheers originally and
now you own a brewery and I think that's
amazing you own a brewery Upstate right
yeah I love Upstate New York do you love
it I absolutely adore it yeah yeah a
faith American Brewing Company that's
that's what I what was your why did you
want to do that uh the Water yeah it's
uh it's I've had this property up there
uh for 26 years yeah and uh I'd walk the
trails and hike and stuff and see the
water and I think gosh we got to do
something with this it used to be a
really really you know successful Place
prosperous place there was a dairy farm
and a a big cauliflower Farm the largest
cauliflower Farm on the East Coast for
years wow and uh it old old folks that
come from that town say oh yeah I used
to pack cauliflower pundits up there at
uh you know your old place and they go
yeah okay they also used to they also
used to trap black minks so you know
obviously that's a different story too
yeah um in any case um the beer seems
like the natural thing and my wife
actually suggested the beer as well and
we go through a big battle about she got
great ideas yeah she's just karaoke
alcohol you did the be because you know
because I said so and I said I know I
never thought of it
before I like her already
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home